my fear in life is balding is it I can't
be fat and bald you know what I'm saying
yeah listen dog when you're fat you got
to pick struggles very intelligently
Theo really yeah man I don't get to be
you know you can have a kind of a smelly
day and get away with it because you're
an old handsome [ __ ] not me damn if
I'm fat and smelly it sticks forever I
gotta make sure I'm smelling yeah if you
wake up forget deodorant oh little musty
I wake up and forget deodorant that'll
log that's a damn ecosystem huh I do it
I will it will follow me like Pig Pen oh
you love moss on the North side I can't
be fat and bald man yeah yeah cause
you're a bigger guy man what's it like
being bigger well you got to make sure
every chair won't hurt you or break you
you look first up you say well you've
got to give a test you know what I'm
saying for sure you got to ease into it
yeah man damn I don't think about that
kind of stuff and we always have a big
guy since you were young yeah dude I was
fat as a kid man I've just always
struggled with like and I think it's a
part of my my personal mental so Health
struggles right we all have our own
things and our own demons and vices and
for me
I could literally go on a three-day
cocaine Bender right now and wake up on
the fourth day and be like well that was
a lot of fun and not do it again for
weeks or months you know but dude you
[ __ ] set some snacks out somewhere
and don't let me hover around them more
than two or three minutes I'll start
filling my pockets up like I'm in jail
and I'm never going to see them again
yeah I'm saying like for sure you want
them snacks yeah yeah I'm all about
snacks does it scare you away does it
worry you yeah all the time dude I want
to be this fat I don't want people
commenting on who's gonna die it's gonna
happen for sure you know what I mean
it might be me right now
a couple of ghost accounts you know it's
like you don't want to go through that
and yeah I'm on the I got a nutritionist
now I've been working on working on my
weight this year more than I have in a
long time but I also don't worry about
as much as I should because I've been on
this roller coaster my whole life where
I'm a little more plump right now but I
can show you pictures when I was less
plump and I can show you pictures when I
was more plump I just kind of you know
it's kind of part of what I what I deal
with just trying to get on the other
side of the mountain I know they do a
lot of those surgeries and stuff if
you've ever done anything like that
where they like get into your system or
whatever yeah I'm just not with that
don't you know I'm not gonna I don't
know man don't [ __ ] don't get cut on and
all that old [ __ ] yeah yeah I just don't
know what people do you know you know
what the most selfish thing I can say
right now is but it's real
I've heard when you do the surgery it
[ __ ] with your ability to intake
anything which I would love for that to
be the case with food but like they were
like well you can't drink more than a
half gallon of water a day on or it'll
make you sick
what like I don't want to spend my life
I'd rather die young yeah not young like
this but like you know than having to
measure your water you have to measure
my water you know what I'm saying
there's like just a little stuff like
yeah when they started explaining some
of the stuff to me because I went and
talked to the dude you know what I mean
like there's no there's not a fat person
on Earth that can afford the surgery
that hasn't at least went and talked to
the person about the surgery yeah you
know and when he started explaining it
to me I was just like and he was honest
enough too he's like look man
I think that if you just put your mind
to it you'll lose the weight again it's
been proven that you can lose the weight
what hasn't been proven is that I can
keep the weight off so that's what we
got to figure out next it's such a
struggle for so many people man you know
I I I don't know what that's like I know
it's a struggle is like but I don't know
what that struggle is like do you feel
though also you're so recognizable as
this like Larger than Life character do
you feel like being larger you almost
have to be larger no dude it's like
I think the real side of it is it's a
decision to live and I'm just starting
to make that decision I spent most of my
life yeah not giving a [ __ ] if I live or
not just not giving a [ __ ] I feel like
yeah I tell people to this day like when
I really start to get angry I have to
I've had to have this moment with a few
grown men in my life where I'm like dog
do I look like somebody that cares like
you should really assess that before you
talk to me crazy like I have everything
written on my body to show you I don't
give a [ __ ] about a lot you know what I
mean it's like I'm just starting to give
a [ __ ] like I'm just looking at my 14
year old daughter like
I used to be like if I could just live
till she's 18 I'd be okay now I'm
starting to be like I'd like to meet my
grandkids I think yeah you know it's
like you're starting to think about [ __ ]
you didn't think about before ain't that
kind of magical when those ideas come in
your head that think make you believe
you care about yourself yes that's
insane it's little stuff that's like I
think I do want to meet my grandchildren
yeah so that's what made me hire a
nutritionist before it was like a chore
to be like I just want to stay alive
until she's 18 so I don't create any
more unnecessary trauma in her life yeah
you know what I'm saying and then it's
like you know it was about her and then
it's kind of like selfishly now it's
about me it's like I don't know man I
kind of want to hang out with the
grandkids I kind of want to I kind of
want to see where this thing ends up
with her yeah I want to see what jelly
yeah when jelly starts to kind of
coagulate I want to be there yeah for
sure I want to kind of look because like
now she's cool enough at 14 that I'm
like dude I bet she's gonna kick ass at
25. I want to see that yeah you know
what I'm saying like oh dude she's gonna
be a whole different human at 35 [ __ ] I
didn't know my ear for my [ __ ] at 25.
wait till she's 35 I'm like [ __ ] I'm
live for 30 years not 20. you know what
I mean like oh God damn I'm gonna have
to [ __ ] stay alive I'm gonna have to
do a pushover
s hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one